this video was sponsored by brilliant
dog lasers have transformed science
today they're used in all manner of
research from super cult atoms to
astrophysics to biophysics in fact the
most recent Nobel Prize in Physics was
awarded for groundbreaking inventions in
the field of laser physics what's unique
about them is the fact that they produce
light of one wavelength which is
coherent that means that the crests of
laser light waves are like marching
soldiers all moving together with the
same speed and same constant separation
from one another this allows scientists
to do really cool things and the more
powerful the laser the cooler the things
we can do a modern research lasers are
really impressive pieces of kit okay not
quite that impressed this is the central
laser facility in Oxfordshire in the UK
the facility is used for a variety of
research projects including recreating
the conditions inside stars and even
imaging the motions of individual
electrons in chemical reactions they
have a variety of lasers but in
particular they have a hugely powerful
one called
Vulcan Vulcan outputs so much energy
that for a tiny fraction of a second
it's more than ten thousand times more
powerful than the entire national grid
in fact it's so powerful that the beam
in Vulcan would melt the components that
make up of the laser if the scientists
who designed it hadn't used a clever
trick this trick is what allows modern
research lasers to be as powerful as
they are and it's what won the most
recent Nobel Prize in Physics in this
video we're going to talk about how it
works we'll come back to this laser and
how it's so powerful
later price to begin with all lasers
work by a process called stimulated
emission in fact that's where the word
laser comes from it's an acronym for
light amplification by stimulated
emission of radiation stimulated
emission works by carefully selecting a
material known as a gain medium which
amplifies an initial pulse of light in
this material individual atoms can be in
a ground state or in an excited state
there are no in-betweens an atom is
either excited or it's not
now if the atom is excited then it can
jump down to the ground state by
emitting a flash of light called a photo
this flash of light has a very specific
wavelength associated with it unique to
the material the atom is made of and so
it will be the same for every atom of
that gain medium that jumps from the
excited state to the ground state lasers
work because of an effect where an atom
in an excited state is much more likely
to jump down to the ground state and so
emits that specific flash of light when
an identical flash of light passes
nearby this process then allows for a
smaller initial flash of light to pass
through the game medium and be amplified
several times by passing several excited
atoms causing them to jump down to the
ground state and emit their identical
flashes of light thus becoming a really
strong signal if you put a mirror at
either end of the game medium then you
can repeat this process as many times as
you like if you keep raising atoms in
two excited States by for example an
electric field and then release the
light at one end that gives you a pulse
of laser light but it's only the first
part of a modern research laser like
Vulcan because while this initial laser
signal is weak it can be amplified
through other components but there's a
problem as I said before if you try and
amplify this signal up to the power
outputs of Vulcan or the Death Star then
the density of energy that you're
putting through the optical components
like lenses and amplifiers is enough to
damage those components so you just have
to find a Nobel Prize winning way around
it that way is called chirped pulse
amplification and this is how it works
the reason that the laser beam would
melt the glass is because it would
deliver an incredible amount of energy
in a very short time when I say a very
short time I mean about 200 femtoseconds
or not 0.2 million millionths of a
second chirped pulse amplification works
by first stretching the laser pulse to a
million times its original length so it
now lasts a few nanoseconds this
stretched signal is then amplified
increasing the energy in the pulse until
the energy density of the pulse is just
less than
the threshold for damaging the
components in the laser then just before
the beam hits its target in the final
part of the laser the pulse is
compressed back to its original shorter
length in time the amount of energy in
the pulse is still the same but it's now
over a shorter period of time so the
energy density is much much higher so
you deliver to the target an energy
density that is way higher than your
optical components could tolerate think
of how the Death Star fires if it fired
its main beam from within the space
station it would damage yourself so
instead it combines several lower power
laser beams into one massively powerful
beam just before it hits the target
except while the Deathstar combines and
focuses beams which are spread out in
space modern research lasers combine
beams spread out in time and while the
Death Star does this through a focusing
dish a bit like a lens research lasers
accomplish the same thing through
another standard piece of kit
diffraction gratings break up lights
diffracting that is basically deflecting
different wavelengths of light by
different amounts red light gets
deflected the most and blue light the
least a bit like a prism except remember
how at the start of the video I said
that light from a laser is all the same
wavelength so if you put it through a
diffraction grating it's all going to be
diffracted by the same amount right well
not quite because of a variety of
physical processes that literally have
whole textbooks written about them laser
light actually occupies a very narrow
band of wavelengths not just one number
so when you put it through a diffraction
grating it does spread out in space ever
so slightly the fact that it gets spread
out in space is crucial to the trick of
chirped pulse amplification because if
you use a diffraction grating and
normally a reflecting diffraction
grating is used position it at an angle
with some lenses another grating and a
mirror you can create a pulse stretcher
the key part here is on the right notice
how the longer wavelength red light
travels a shorter distance than the
shorter wavelength blue light because
all light travels at the same speed this
means that while the red and blue lights
arrived at the same time in the laser
when they leave the system the red light
does so slightly ahead of the blue light
the duration of the pulse of lights has
increased and its colors spread out like
a rainbow in time at this point you can
amplify your signal which Vulcan does
through neodymium glass amplifiers and
then when you're done compress the pulse
of light back to its original short
duration using a similar setup of
diffraction gratings but this time blue
light has a shorter path to travel and
the red light travels a longer path so
you undo the stretching process and
you're left with a short pulse of
extremely amplified laser light this
whole process is extremely delicate and
needs to be carefully monitored which
explains why Vulcan is such a huge piece
of kit but it allows it to generate
incredible energy densities in 2005 it
won a Guinness world record for being
the most powerful focused laser system
in the world
generating a petawatt pulse that's a
billion million watts and when I was
there they let me fire it I'm about to
fire on those powerful lasers in the
world and it's touchscreen commence
primary ignition
[Applause]
[Music]
that may have been a bit anticlimactic
but that was very cool for me so modern
research lasers are only possible
because of chirped pulse amplification
stretching out to your pulse of laser
lights before amplifying it and then re
compressing it back to a short
incredibly intense pulse by doing this
we can access incredibly high energy
densities even bringing the physics of
faraway stars to earth for a fraction of
a second I was assured by the scientists
at the research facility however that we
are still a very very long way off the
construction of this particular
technological terror yes in this video I
talked about how lasers only possible
because of a quantum phenomenon that
means that star wars cat videos and I
don't know life-changing medical science
is only possible because of the work of
physicists at the start of the 20th
century I was lucky enough to study
quantum mechanics in depth in my physics
degree and it was awesome one of the
best aspects of my degree was the fact
that the teaching was based around
solving problems every week I would have
several sheets of questions to answer
based on material covered in the
lectures personally I don't really
understand something until I tried my
hand at some questions and gotten to
grips with the ideas you don't have to
commit to a degree to do this however in
fact you can learn by solving problems
in quantum theory along with loads of
other topics on brilliant zorg I'm so
happy that brilliant have sponsored a
bunch of my science videos because their
philosophy of learning through solving
problems and in particular making sure
you know it's okay to make mistakes
because that's how you learn is exactly
how I think people should learn
brilliant is freemium meaning that parts
of the website are free so you
absolutely should check those out and
parts like they're curated courses are
accessible with a premium subscription
if you like the sound of one of those
then go to brilliant org slash Simon
Clarke and the first 200 people to do so
will get 20% off their subscription
thank you so much for watching the video
and for making it all the way to the end
thanks also to the team at the NLF for
inviting me to film that's Helen Emily
and Carrie thank you for showing me
around there is another video coming out
of that trip on a different topic which
I won't spoil just yet but we coming out
in a couple of weeks so I'm really
really
about that one I got to interview
someone very exciting so yeah that'll be
on the channel in a couple of weeks if
you enjoyed the video do give a like if
you'd like to find out more about the
stuff in the video that in case you
didn't pick up on it the numbers on the
screen are references or footnotes in
the description there's a bunch more
information but if you want to see more
like this then you can subscribe to the
channel and comment below with you know
encouragement if you'd like to see more
videos like this but I'm babbling if you
like the video I'm glad please do give
it a like or give it share and I'll see
you next one
[Music]